- À 9 ans, la petite Ariel
est heureuse de pouvoir lever
le voile sur les menstruations
avec sa maman
lors de cet atelier.
(en mandarin)
Elle n'aura pas honte
d'en parler quand ses règles
viendront. Ariel souhaite
que plus de jeunes filles
se sentiront comme elle.
(en mandarin)
La maman d'Ariel, elle, a dû
faire cet apprentissage seule.
Stigmatisation menstruelle
et silence honteux ont
longtemps accompagné les règles.
L'organisme With Red organise
ces ateliers dans son musée
sur les menstruations
afin de briser les tabous
entourant la santé menstruelle.
Dans le système scolaire
taïwanais, le sujet
est souvent vu en vitesse.
L'organisme With Red milite
aussi pour l'équité menstruelle,
c'est-à-dire favoriser l'accès
aux produits d'hygiène féminine
à celles qui sont moins
fortunées et qui en ont le plus
besoin. Le problème est criant
dans plusieurs pays d'Asie.
Selon les données
recueillies par With Red et
sa jeune fondatrice de 24 ans,
Vivi Lin, une femme sur 10
à Taïwan n'aurait pas accès
à des produits hygiéniques
quand  e e en a besoin.
À Ottawa, le gouvernement
allouera 25 millions de dollars
pour combattre l'iniquité
À Ottawa, le gouvernement
allouera 25 millions de dollars
pour combattre l'iniquité
menstruelle au Canada,
souvent liée à la pauvreté.
David Yeh est venu
à l'atelier sur la santé
à l'atelier l l la santé
et l'équité menstruelles
avec ses jumelles de 10 ans.
(en mandarin)
Il croit que les hommes aussi
ivivivent en savoir plus pour or
en parler. Sophie et Dora,
elles, pourront discuter
ensemble de ce qu'elles viennent
d'apprendre.
(en mandarin)
Partager ses expériences
de toutes sortes avec sa soeur,
sans g, , , ça n'a pas de prix.
Ici Phillipe Leblanc,
Radio-Canada, Taipei.